life continually requires
that we write down a few words of thanks
for holidays
meals presents or people's place in our
hearts
however too often our messages end up
flat or
somewhat unconvincing we say that the
dinner was
wonderful the present brilliant and the
holiday
the best ever all of which may be true
while failing to get at what really
touched or moved us
to render our messages more effective we
might take a lesson from an unexpected
quarter
the history of art many paintings and
poems
are in effect a series of thank you
notes to parts of the world
they are thank yous for the sunset in
springtime the river valley at dawn
the last days of autumn or the face of a
beloved
what distinguishes great from mediocre
art is in large measure the level of
detail
with which the world has been studied a
talented artist
is first and foremost someone who takes
us into the specifics of the reasons
why an experience or a place felt
valuable they don't merely tell us that
spring is
nice they zero in on the particular
contributing factors
to this niceness leaves that have the
softness of a newborn's hands
the contrast between a warm sun and a
sharp breeze
the plaintiff cry of baby blackbirds
the more the poet moves from
generalities
to specifics the more the scene comes
alive
in our minds the same holds true
in painting a great painter goes beneath
a general impression of pleasure
in order to select and emphasize the
truly attractive features of a given
landscape
they show the sunlight filtering through
the leaves of the trees
and reflecting off of a pool of water in
the road they draw attention to the
craggy upper slopes of a mountain
or the way a sequence of ridges and
valleys opens up in the distance
they've asked themselves with unusual
rigor what it is that
they particularly appreciated about a
scene
and faithfully transcribed their salient
impressions
some of the reason why great artists are
rare is that our minds
are not well set up to understand why we
feel
as we do we register our emotions in
broad strokes
and arrive an overall sense of our moods
long before we grasp the basis upon
which they rest we're bad at traveling
upstream
from our impressions to their source it
feels frustrating to have to ask too
directly
what was really pleasing about a present
or why exactly a person seemed
charming to have dinner with but we can
be confident
that if our minds have been affected the
reasons
why they've been so will be lodged
somewhere in consciousness
as well waiting to be uncovered with
deafness
and patience we stand to realize that it
wasn't so much that the food was
delicious but that the potatoes in
particular had an intriguing
rosemary and garlic flavor to them a
friend
wasn't just nice they brought in a
hugely sensitive and generous tone to
bear in asking us
what it had been like for us in
adolescence after our father died
and the camera wasn't just a great
present it has an immensely satisfying
rubbery grip
and a reassuringly clunky shutter sound
that evokes a
sturdier better older world
the details will be there waiting for us
to catch them
through our mental sieve praise works
best
the more specific it can be we know this
in love
the more a partner can say what it is
they appreciate about us
the more real their affection can feel
it's when they've studied the shape of
our fingers
when they've recognized and appreciated
the quirks of our character
when they've clocked the words we like
or the way we end a phone call
that the praise starts to count the
person who's given a dinner party or
sent us a present is no different they
too hunger for praise
in its specific rather than in its
general forms
we don't have to be great artists to
send effective thank you notes
we just need to locate and hold on
tightly to
two or three highly detailed reasons
for our gratitude
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected
areas of life click now to learn more
you